from cyborgs metal robots to astounding
Esper powers the one punch man series
sure has some great abilities to offer
for its heroes and villains though their
primary end goal is to be stronger and
surpass each other these abilities
managed to heighten the power levels of
the heroes and amplify the stakes of the
villains and overall make the series
more unique among these abilities what
are the best ones you wish you had to
answer that question without further ado
let's get to the top ten abilities in
the one punch man series
[Applause]
speed is sure one of the best
superpowers a hero can receive but in
the one punch man universe the speed
quirk is taken to the next level when
it's given to two men with ninja skills
speeder sonic and flashy flash the
former is a hired mercenary who crosses
paths with Saitama and gets a badly
damaged groin and the latter is an
s-class hero who can take down dragon
level threats instantly when it comes to
having speed the users lightning-fast
movement is enough to confuse their
opponent and this gives the chance for
them to do a deadly sneak attack which
is exactly what villains like speeder
sonic do having great speed also means
great defense because you can dodge any
attack your opponent throws at you and
even take a fast retreat if things go
bad it's also a plus if you're using the
ability along with a weapon such as
flashy flash using his sword to take
down his enemies while dashing around
them in an interview with the author
he claimed that speeder sonic can
surpass the speeds of s-class heroes
like Jane Austen metal bat and with his
abilities in hand sonic could even
defeat the deep-sea King while in his
dehydrated form so what other proof do
you need to confirm that this power is
s-class
if Marvel's got Iron Man the metal
Knights surely the Iron Man of the one
punch man universe he's not only one of
the ranking st heroes but also one of
the most powerful and influential
members of the hero association under
the giant mechs he's a man called
Beaufoy who has a love for weaponry and
advanced technology metal knight's power
lies within his robots and has a
reputation for using powerful weaponry
without caring about what his
surroundings are both ways a favorite
robot is a battle robot a giant silver
robot with powerful cannons attached to
its back this suit comes with full
flight capabilities attached rocket and
its protective metal skin is strong
enough to withstand even the most
powerful attacks the robot gives an
advantage for Beaufoy as he can stay a
safe distance away from the battle and
also use weapons without thinking twice
when it comes to his preferred method of
combat Beaufoy isn't limited to his
battle robot and has varied types of
robots in his arsenal each of them
specializing in different aspects so
with his robot army by his side both
ways armor is sure one of the best
abilities to have
[Music]
even though it may seem weak compared to
other abilities in the one punch man
universe you'd be surprised to know
martial arts can still triumph even the
best heroes if used wisely with practice
the best examples for this are Bank and
Garo fangs ranked among the top three
heroes of the one punch man universe and
his disciple guru also dubbed as the
infamous hero hunter has a strength that
matches all of S Class Heroes combined
martial arts is one heck of an ability
to have if you're fighting close combat
with Gaara being living proof of it even
in his weakened state Gaara
managed to fend off attacks of 8/8 class
heroes and even knocked them down one by
one not to mention his battle with an
improved Geno's with Gaara managing to
take the upper hand of the battle in
many instances using his skill and wit
the author of the one punch man even
claims that his max potential Garo can
even defeat Boros in close combat using
his martial arts alone which means if
you can master it your two hands are the
best weapons you can use
[Music]
even though speedo sonic has his speed
he sure has a lot to learn when it comes
to his swordsmanship but on the other
hand one who's mastered the art of speed
and swordsmanship is kamikaze better
known by his alias atomic samurai though
he doesn't have much screen time as the
other heroes when atomic samurai gets
into battle you can really see the
potential of his abilities with his
speed and strength atomic samurai can
cut his opponents to pieces in the blink
of an eye he also has great agility and
this is a plus point for his defense as
he can dodge many attacks within seconds
without getting even a single hit
wonderful to his powers to test is his
battle with Melser guard in this battle
atomic samurai was bold enough to face
him head-on counter many of his attacks
and unleash the peak of his ability the
atomic slash if you have a sword and are
looking for speed and defense this is
the ability you should wish for
in those abilities you wish you had
we're sure you dreamed of shape-shifting
at least once and in the one punch man
universe the power of shape-shifting
unfortunately falls into the hands of a
villain Melser guard Melser guard has
the ability to form wings hammers blades
extra limbs or any object he wishes
through his body this also gives him the
ability to do anything with his body
giving him a larger defense and offense
one of his sub forms also created due to
the shape-shifting abilities has wings
and is capable of flight at great speeds
one of the other pros of his
shape-shifting ability is that he can
separate and multiply himself as much as
he wants so no matter how many opponents
he faces he can multiply for the number
of opponents that each of these clones
will have the same power as the original
melzar guard this makes him if not
obvious of course a tougher opponent to
deal with his strength mainly lies
within his shape-shifting ability so you
can see how much of an influence his
powers really are we've only mentioned
common quirks so far but how about
something rare water empowerment is an
ability related to the quirks owners
habitats and allows him to gain strength
using the energy stored in the water if
it wasn't obvious by now the one we're
talking about is the deep-sea King from
one punch man still carrying the legacy
as one of the greatest threats faced by
the heroes this villain mostly relies
upon his water empowerment ability to
gain augmented strength and speed his
strength even managed to bring down
s-class heroes like booty pooty prisoner
and his newly developed speed was enough
to surpass Sonics when his water
empowered powers are activated the
deep-sea Kings body changes as well
making him larger and even more muscular
however one downside of this ability is
that if he stays in a dry area for a
long period of time or gets inflicted by
attacks similar to Geno's his form may
shift back and he may become vulnerable
but the boost his ability gives him is
enough to give this ability a spot on
our list
now let's accept it no matter how many
fists you throw it your opponent is not
gonna be enough if you don't play the
fight with your brains this has been a
lesson for countless heroes as they
gradually learn the skill of the
villains through battle but a person
who's always one step forward is child
Emperor this twelve-year-old has a
genius-level intellect it always plans
his moves before the fight though he has
the strength to match a class heroes
strength is rarely a factor he
prioritizes in battle as he prefers to
take time to understand his opponent
create opportunities in battle and then
put various strategies into play before
approaching the fight this ability
proves tough for many of the one punch
man villains as they rely on their fists
during the battle and leave many
openings in their fights which a genius
tactician can use to aim carefully
planned attacks having a great intellect
also important when handling dragon
level attacks because you'll be the only
one who can grip a sense of the threat
and take precautions rather than rushing
straight into the battle child Emperor
proved this as he took the time to
analyze the battleship of borås during
his invasion rather than heading
straight out to battle besides being a
genius never hurts does it
at number three we have cyborgs powers
you know what we're talking about don't
you if your friendly neighborhood cyborg
who tried to incinerate his sensei Janos
but when it comes to cyborgs powers
Jenna isn't the only one who should be
mentioned we shouldn't forget the
s-class hero drive Knight though he
rarely gets screen time and it's still
not clear if he's a cyborg
or a robot the cool thing about cyborgs
powers is that it not only greatly
augments your physical strength but is
capable of increasing your defense and
offense capabilities and provide gadgets
suitable for every situation a good
example of this is generals tracking
down Saitama using his visionary senses
in their battle and also those powerful
blasts see unleashes with his weaponry
his mecha enhanced body also gives him
the edge when it comes to speed and
reflexes and regeneration and flight
capabilities are also several additions
that come along with disability both
jenos and drive Knight are capable of
transforming their body parts to match
the situation genna's can transform both
his arms to powerful weapons and drive
Knight can transform his arm to a sword
named silver which can cut multiple
dragon level enemies at once with all
these cool gadgets and features who
doesn't yearn for this skill
[Music]
anyone who watched mob psycho sure knows
ESPA powers aren't to be handled lightly
but the Esper powers of thought samake
can sure surpass the powers of many
other heroes the main ability of Esper's
is psychokinesis aka the ability to move
and control objects through one's mind a
load and characters like that samake
have the ability to lift the entire z
city without breaking a sweat which
explains how much potential disability
has tatsumaki sister Fubuki has mastered
psychic combat which allows her to use
the objects in her environment to
directly attack her opponents this way
it's easier for her to handle multiple
opponents at once
ESPA powers also give the user more
control over his or her mind and renders
the effects of mind control useless so
if you're heading down the mind-master
route this is surely an ability you
should have
taught you nothing
you saw this one coming now didn't you
after all how can we talk about one
punch man without talking about the
power of Saitama and all the
supervillains he's faced in the one
punch man universe most heroes and
villains rely on their physical strength
so having the strength of a superhuman
is always a plus we don't want to go to
the strength levels of Saitama but there
are many other characters like carnage
Kabuto the monster king Orochi and even
the all-mighty Boris who rely on the
excessive physical strength in battle
one of the cool things about superhuman
strength is that it can be divided into
levels as an example Boris was much
different in his final form rather than
the original form he started the battle
in so how far can physical strength go
the answer for that is probably
saitama's one punch because what else do
you need if you can end your opponent
with just one punch
that being said superhuman strength is
surely the best ability to have in the
one punch man universe but if you're
planning on reaching the levels of
Saitama make sure you have a pretty
tough training schedule so did you enjoy
this video if you did it let us know
what your favorite ability is in a
series that you wish you had we post
anime content every week so make sure to
click the subscribe button and hit the
bell notification to keep yourself
updated with the latest videos see you
next time on Vinny tube
[Music]